[Aplausos]
uno cree que un enfermo es una persona
sin salud y no es sólo eso una persona
una persona que está enferma
no está firme en trabajo en ilusiones en
sueños en familia
en apoyo
en introspección en retrospección y
aparte no tiene salud es bastante
distinto
el 11 de enero del 2007 a mí me tocó
pasar por una situación
muy particular en el mismo día me
descubrieron una
deficiencia una insuficiencia renal
crónica
me descubrieron un síndrome de ekon que
es el tener las piernas temblorosas un
quiste en el cerebro y un síndrome de
melancólico
un combo bastante completo
entendí que a partir de ese día pasaba a
pertenecer al mundo de los invisibles o
al mundo de los anónimos
me tuve que hacer diálisis por cuatro
años con todo lo que eso significa las
diálisis son tres veces por semana
cuatro horas cada vez yo perdí 1.820
horas laborales en estos casi cuatro
años lo que es terrible para cualquiera
de nosotros no solamente eso sino que
perdí mi trabajo cuando se enteraron que
de que yo estaba enfermo me despiden
entonces me tuve que encontrar sobre
varios escenarios primero sobre mi
enfermedad sobre no estar firme como
dice allí enfermo o bien en firme no
firme
sobre quedarme sin trabajo
y además ver como enfrentaba esta nueva
enfermedad que hasta ahora había sido
absolutamente invisible y asintomática
ese mismo día me di cuenta que
aumentaron invisibilidad porque dejé ser
javier artigas para transformarse para
transformarme en el enfermo 30 15 75 es
real esto que estoy mostrando esto lo
tenía yo arriba de mí de mi camilla
yo me sentí que yo javier artigas era el
saler y de los sanos
el envidioso de los años y no era así
pero ellos me lo hicieron sentir así la
salud de miles yo sentir así
susan sontag que es una escritora
norteamericana dice que nosotros al
nacer poseemos una doble ciudadanía
el mundo de los enfermos pertenece al
mundo de los más tristes pero al nacer
nos otorgan dos pasaportes y que
inevitablemente uno es de los enfermos
lo vamos a tener que utilizar en algún
momento tarde o temprano lo vamos a
tener que utilizar
a mí a mis 37 años
pese a pasar a pensar que pertenecía al
mundo
de los sanos me toco regalo no solamente
todas las enfermedades que les conté
sino además la invisibilidad
yo creí pertenecer a qué
perdón pensé que que era un ser
absolutamente gris o anónimo pese a que
el gris es un color hermoso
muchas veces se ha utilizado en milán y
en parís para mostrar colecciones
fabulosas yo era el peor gris el gris
más triste del gris de los subterráneos
el gris de los hospitales el gris de la
angustia y de la desesperanza
e incluso llega a pensar que era de el
gris
frío de las estatuas era absolutamente
no sé cómo realmente explicarlo pero era
muy desesperante muy desesperante y al
mismo al mismo tiempo de mucha angustia
un día por casualidad o causalidad
logré salir de esa de esa visibilidad
perdón de esa invisibilidad
un día ya sin recursos y como se dice
aquí raspando el arroyo la olla estaba
muy mal económicamente y decidimos
alquilar un pequeño espacio en nuestra
casa para la plataforma hervida en bing
es una plataforma si ustedes no la
conocen es una plataforma de rentas
vacacionales es la plataforma de renta
vacacionales más grande del mundo tiene
un valor de 40 billones de dólares
el primer día no fue fantástico cayó un
profesor de chino de stanford y pasamos
días fabulosos el segundo día llegó
carlos y grace que son nuestros actuales
socios en brasil y desarrollo nuestro
negocio en brasil
el tercer día cayeron unas personas de
canadá que eran absolutamente fabulosos
el quinto de una familia de alemania
y también nos hicimos súper amigos pero
el sexto llegó este personaje que es un
escritor argentino que ha ganado el
premio juan rulfo
ha hecho una recorrida por toda
latinoamérica presentando sus cuentos
messi es un perro
y algunas más y se ha hecho muy famoso
y tuvo la desgracia que al segundo día
en el nivel de mi casa infarto
infarto o sea no les estoy diciendo que
tuvo una una breve molestias infarto
alejandra que está aquí y es mi esposa
lo subió a nuestra super máquina
y como ella trabaja en la jefatura de
relaciones internacionales del senado
agarro un patrullero que estaba ahí en
la mitad de camino y les dijo por favor
usted haga una cápsula saben lo que es
una cápsula una cápsula va al auto
presidencial en el medio dos patrulleros
motos y van rodeando y llevando el
vehículo presidencial lo más rápido que
se pueda para que el presidente de la
persona de turno llegue sin ningún tipo
de entorpecimiento
estará nuestra cápsula presidencial
con este auto que lo máximo que daba era
60 70 kilómetros por hora
alejandra lo llevó y le logró salvar la
vida un trayecto que casi se hace en 40
minutos desde mi casa hasta el hospital
ella lo hizo en 16 habla de la pericia
de ella yo le diría que hay que hacer un
aplauso porque fue fantástica
el médico pignol o el cardiólogo nos
dijo si hubiesen demorado cuatro minutos
más
hernández hubiese muerto
y la verdad es que yo no participé de
esa historia aunque a partir de esta
historia que yo les acabo de contar se
han escrito miles de libros han hecho
obras de teatro yo no estaba ese día yo
lo único que hice fue hablar por
teléfono con algunos médicos que conocía
porque yo trabajo en la medicina les
pedí que por favor lo atendieran lo
antes posible que no pasara por urgencia
que fuera directo hemodinamia y le
pusieran los stent que necesitaban
eso se hizo y ya les digo en 16 minutos
él se pudo salvar esta fue la
descripción que escribió hernán en la
plataforma del bien vi sobre nosotros
excelente vivienda para huéspedes
sedentarios y con propensiones de
infarto de miocardio
la zona es preciosa y pose de
comunicación directa con los mejores
hospitales del mundo son mentira
los anfitriones que había alejandra se
convierten en el instante en ángeles de
la guarda y te salvan la vida sin
conocerte observen que yo no estaba no
sea javier alejandré dicen yo no estaba
te llevaban muy rápido al hospital y su
propio coche mientras estás muriendo y
después de quedar en la sala de espera
hasta que los médicos se te ponen un
bypass no permiten que quedasen la
depresión y que te sientas solo te traen
libros para que leas además no te
quieren colar los días que te que que te
quedas demás en su casa muy recomendable
este se obvia
y es uno de los siete millonarios del
mundo menores de treinta y siete años
cuando pasó todo esto esto fue en
diciembre del 2015 después de estar muy
muy agotado por toda la situación que
habíamos pasado decidí irnos unos días
no tan lejos porque no nos da el
presupuesto antes de punta del este
en el sur de uruguay hay un bañero que
llama a pesar de que ni siquiera ha
legislado yo lo he aquí lado mi cuñado y
le dije vayámonos un día nos fuimos el
31 de diciembre aquí se dice peaje no sé
dónde están en las carreteras se dice
peaje cuando llegamos al primer peaje
nos llega un mail de este individuo y
cuando yo lo veo
le digo alejandra alejandra me manda un
mail y el séptimo millonario del mundo
un 31 de diciembre y levante la mano
quien cree que esto es real
si no es para yo pensé que el spam o sea
dirige alejandra decir que sí que haga
lo que quiera que venga cuando quiera
al segundo peaje 16 kilómetros después
dice ah bueno ok si hago lo que quiero
voy a buscar un buen ahora y me lo tomo
y uno entiende más o menos cómo son los
gringos yo trabajo con ellos y yo dije
que hicimos
a los 20 minutos llega un mail y dice
acabo de conseguir un vuelo voy para
allá 31 de diciembre no le importa va a
pasar
el fin de año arriba del avión con tal
de llegar el primero de enero
será el primero de enero a las 10 de la
mañana nosotros totalmente atónitos
mirando por la ventana a ver qué era lo
que pasaba
y de repente llega una persona con unos
sujetos una bermuda negra una remerita
negra y un sombrero de paja y yo digo
alejandra este será el billonario del
mundo
en siga entra nosotros dejamos entrar o
nos secuestra
o nos dará la mayor fortuna del mundo lo
dejamos entrar y él nos dice cuéntenme
qué es lo que pasó cuenta en media
historia le contamos la historia muy
rápidamente pero mi gran preocupación y
la activa pasará a partir de ahí y del
bus que quiere sacar realmente y él me
dice me puedo quedar 10 días y mi cabeza
muy paranoica y que tiene muchos
trastornos te dije pero alguien sabe que
vos estás acá
y él me dice no nadie y yo dije sabemos
ahora mismo a la embajada porque si los
secuestran el primero voy a ser yo el
primero que van a venir a buscar soy yo
él me dice no no no yo necesito absoluta
este
quiero estar despejado quiero estar
despreocupado de todo lo que pasa y yo
decía me agarra la cabeza por favor esto
no puede pasarme a mí o sea pasar de la
invisibilidad a esto es un goteo es un
shock muy muy fuerte
pero
esto posteriormente a todo esto que yo
les estuve contando
en abril marzo abril del 2016
dudo habernos hecho muchas consultas
como grupo de sangre tienen ustedes que
grupo de sangre tiene hernán que
hicieron ustedes por hernán etcétera
etcétera y para que ustedes crean que
realmente porque hasta ahora parece que
fue una historia quiero que vean un
vídeo de lo que él comentó en una tele
vancouver
este y saquen sus propias conclusiones
si podemos poner el vídeo por favor
hoy estoy en esto
hoy
y
para que la sistemas de software gris
hasta la fecha
más
dirigió espacios
[Aplausos]
pero para que vean que también son real
ahí estás yo en mi casa está dejando
está mi hija estoy yo tomando mate que
es la bebida típica de uruguay
y acá se dan cuenta que lo que pasa ella
es mi hija yo me paro en el medio y yo
está pensando o prestando atención en
otra cosa o sea está bien claro
de hecho salieron o sea que existen
ahora realmente lo que quiero lo que
quiero comentarles porque en un
principio yo quería hacerles un homenaje
a todas ustedes e incluso alejandra pero
alejandra hasta que arriba del escenario
yo sólo quería hacer aquí abajo es que
yo y me encuentro aquí en este escenario
de bogotá porque entendí que salía
adelante de todas las situaciones que yo
pasé de tener un quiste wii y un tumor
en el cerebro de haber pasado por muchas
sesiones de hemodiálisis salí adelante
gracias a ella
salí adelante gracias a mis amigos a mi
imaginación un poco a mi actitud pero
fundamentalmente gracias a ella con ella
creamos nuestra primera plataforma que
es connect medical que lo empezamos con
muy muy poco dinero con lo último que
nos quedaba con 1700 dólares
y llegamos a 14 centros en el mundo con
estos médica lo que hace es coordinar
diálisis para pacientes que quieran
viajar y hasta que hasta que nosotros
creamos esto no podía
hoy tenemos más de 8000 centros en la en
la plataforma y coordinamos diálisis
para más de 68 mil personas
para mí esa es la felicidad más grande
del mundo fuera del éxito o fuera del
fracaso yo siempre digo que borges decía
el éxito del fracaso son los farsantes
para mí el éxito es poder ayudar a la
calidad de vida de una cantidad de
pacientes que no conozco pero comparto
la misma enfermedad
con ella además creamos móvil que un
israel móvil que es una plataforma que
lo que hace es generar a través de esa
fibra que ustedes ven en él en el debajo
de la luz o debajo de la óptica indica
cuando un un conductor está en un estado
crítico o en un estado de ira entonces
el conductor que lo está viendo sabe que
no se debe acercar a él o que no lo debe
seguir sigues las seis emociones
el humano desde que es humano tiene seis
emociones entonces de esa manera
nosotros podemos acercarnos o no de
acuerdo a su emoción si está verde lo
seguimos porque va seguramente
escuchando la mejor música si están azul
está depresivo lo paramos y le decimos
descanse diez minutos y luego siga si
está rojo aléjense
y luego otro que creamos es emociones
que tan inteligentes que lo están viendo
correr allí
con alejandra con su bello rostro pero
no lo pueden ver aquí esto lo que hace
es captar las emociones en tiempo real
ayuda a no solamente a salvar las
emociones sino si alguien nos miente o
no nos miente esto se utiliza en
seguridad luego para ampliar lo
empezamos a utilizar en lo que es la
parte de marketing y también lo
prestamos a utilizar en la parte que en
la parte de retail y salud y como veo
que no me queda mucho tiempo
de goya
a pedir
encarecidamente aunque les cueste
o sea que hablamos en un principio de la
invisibilidad y quiero hablar del poder
yo soy una muestra de ello yo por muchos
momentos me sentí invisible y les
quisiera pedir a cada uno de ustedes que
se levanten si en algún momento se
sintió invisible en esta vida o en este
mundo
me gustaría saber también
quien ha tenido la posibilidad de cuidar
a alguien que se haya sentido invisible
y por último y no menos importante me
gustaría que se levantara quien haya
hecho sentir invisible queriendo o sin
querer a otra persona
entonces para todos ustedes y para
alejandra yo me voy a tomar el
atrevimiento de leerles algo que quizás
me emocione pero me van a perdonar
yo esto lo escribí en un 7 y un día que
no tenía mucho para darle realmente me
faltaba dinero le faltaba salud mi
futuro estaba comprometido
sólo tiene una pluma y escribir esto y
ojalá les guste
y dice así esa molestia bruta
hoy quiero hacerle un homenaje a ella y
hoy a todos ustedes
mis pocos amigos saben que estoy pasando
a aquellos que no lo saben hoy se están
enterando
ella soporta con estoicidad los avatares
de mi enfermedad
soporta mis valores mensuales
fluctuantes mis ánimos mis quistes o
tumores
mis errores y fracasos también la
plenitud de unos éxitos labor desea que
la manera más profunda de sentir una
cosa es sufrir por ella y les juro que
ya sufre día a día conmigo y se toma la
atribución de sufrir un poco más
se inquieta se arrincona se arropa se
mimetiza somatiza el super peine su pelo
rubio y en su día más trágico por mí se
prepara y da batalla porque su sangre
perdón porque por su sangre corre con
vasko at nunca y está lleno de cal y
sana una conjunción no aconsejable y
esto el abrigo yo cuando más cuando mide
a pesar de su metro 77 será
perpetuamente mi pequeña protegida y
estoy seguro de que sin ella
me sería imposible de vivir aquí
quizá deba corregir de ser imposible
vivir
ella aumentó mi cuerpo ante mi
imposibilidad de hacerlo
ella me siguió a lugares en donde más de
uno de ustedes no resistiría minutos
ella me prohibía amor
ella me estruja y me dice que todo
estará bien y quizás hoy lo hacen aún no
teniendo la certeza de que eso
aconteciera quizás sea una mentira
piadosa quizás ser un acto de pasión
pero me permite un desliz y en él
aseguraría que ella daría su propia vida
por salvar la mía
un absoluto acto de honestidad bruta un
bruto e increíble acto de amor
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]